sésamum maintenant elle s'appelle aussi setna
entre autres et elle est le
concept d'intuit du
développement durable elle est le donjon de la
bête marine elle est la gardienne de tous les animaux
qui innovent gagnaient leur vie
si les êtres humains que vous connaissez ne
faisaient pas bien  l'utilisation des ressources qu'elle
peut punir ils l'ennuient elle vit
au fond de la mer le chaman
descendrait au fond de la mer et la
calmerait et lui demanderait ce que les êtres
humains ont fait de mal alors il
communiquait un ou un  médiateur entre
elle et ils ennuyés oh c'est une histoire
derrière ça Hey sésamum mec je m'appelle
Lena Kilson à la maison hey je suis du Groenland
je suis dedans tu as l'air d'origine je suis du
sud du Groenland un endroit appelé le
sommet mais ils je  Je vis
ici depuis 25 ans, je
vis en travaillant avec un
conseil circumpolaire, mais avant cela, j'ai
fait mes études là-bas.
J'ai une formation universitaire à l'
Université du Groenland où j'étais.
la culture de départ et l'histoire de
voir ennuyé je dis n'est pas seulement au Groenland nous
mais en 08 voir je vois que c'est un sens très
grand et profond au-dessus du
cercle polaire hé vous verrez parler des fentes aujourd'hui
les chasseurs et les pêcheurs gagnent leur
vie  de la banquise en utilisant les meilleures
baskets sur la banquise c'est pourquoi
c'est si important parce que sinon
vous ne pourriez aller nulle part en
hiver, vous ne pourriez aller nulle part pour
pêcher ou chasser si vous n'aviez pas de moyen
du voyage
quand vous parlez de la glace de mer
mais que vous entendez partout, c'est qu'ils la
glace de mer se développe plus tard à l'
automne et qu'elle se brise plus tôt
au printemps non seulement agit-elle
comme ça la glace de mer est  de plus en
plus minces, les chasseurs nous montraient la
route qu'ils utilisaient pour naviguer
au cours des dernières années ou au cours des 10 dernières
années, ils changent leurs routes non
seulement sur la pathologie de la glace de mer, mais aussi
sur les calottes glaciaires qu'ils avaient l'habitude de  voyager
sur les
gens un  sommes très attachés à l'endroit où ils
vivent et nous percevons le
monde tel qu'on nous l'enseigne les connaissances
qui vous sont transmises par vos
ancêtres sont très importantes et de très
grande valeur et le jour où vous pourrez voir que
ces connaissances vous n'en aurez plus  être
capable de l'utiliser qui fait que je peux imaginer
que les gens seront très touchés par
cela si vous êtes involontaire ou dans un
an perd nos
compétences éducatives que nous ne sommes plus en mesure d'
utiliser les compétences que nous avons apprises à l'
université ou autre  les
établissements d'enseignement c'est comme ça que je comprends
que c'est d'une grande importance pour eux
je ne dirais pas que j'irais là-bas pour les
aider je n'aime pas le mot enfer
parce que je suis avec moi-même et eux
bien sûr un tu sais  c'est ou peut-être une des personnes
qui sont le plus comment pouvez-vous appeler cela fait des
recherches sur elles savent elles-mêmes
ce qu'elles dirigent elles savent elles-mêmes que des
changements se produisent et elles savent
qu'elles devront également s'adapter aux
changements les chasseurs d'hélas  ka du
Canada et de Carnac ils ont pu parler ensemble
de la banquise et
parler des changements et poser les bonnes
questions et ils ont plus de réponses
aux questions que nous avons
je sais que les gens savent qu'ils vont
devoir s'adapter mais ils  veulent le faire à
leur manière ouais en même
temps j'ai aussi un peu peur que notre
culture obsédante soit dite stressée pour les
œufs donc ce n'est pas seulement le changement climatique
qui stresse notre sortie de la vie c'est
aussi l'animal  les organisations de défense des droits et d'
autres organisations, je pense qu'elles,
comme je l'ai dit auparavant, il y a eu beaucoup
de malentendus et manquent d'
informations sur notre culture que nous
apportons en essayant de présenter l'
image correcte au monde non seulement au
monde extérieur mais aussi au sein de notre  propre
société
lorsque la banquise aura disparu, bien sûr, nos
connaissances à ce sujet auraient disparu avec
la fonte de
vous